wie schon zu Beginn der Sendung
berichtet sind in Hamburg in einer
Kirche der Zeugen Jehovas mehrere
Menschen durch Schüsse getötet worden
weitere wurden verletzt am Telefon ist
jetzt mein Hamburger Kollege Kai sehr
lange Herr sellander was wissen wir über
den Tathergang ja der Schütze soll in
eine Kirche der Zeugen Jehovas gestürmt
sein in einem Stadtteil Alsterdorf kurz
nach 21 Uhr zu der Zeit lief auch eine
Veranstaltung in dem zeitstöckigen
Gebäude in dem auch ein Gebetshaus
untergebracht ist also ein Raum für
Gebete Polizisten waren zufällig in der
Nähe weil sie auf dem Rückweg zu ihre
Unterkunft waren und die Beamten
handelten sehr schnell trugen Menschen
die schwer verletzt waren aus dem
Gebäude einige hatten Schüsse im Bauch
erleben andere Waren selbst aus eigener
Kraft ins Freie gelaufen unter den
Verletzten ist auch eine Schwangere
einige Menschen suchen Schutz wenn einer
Bushaltestelle verstanden sich dort und
mehrere Menschen sind bei dem
mutmaßlichen Amoklauf ums Leben gekommen
zahlreiche Verletzte viele Tote wie
viele Verletzte sind das ist derzeit
nicht bekannt zudem ist auch unglaubt
der Schütze noch am Leben ist
möglicherweise war er in dem Gebäude
könnte sich auch dort so eine Theorie
der Polizei das Leben genommen haben es
geht also keine Hinweise darauf dass er
der Zeit auf der Flucht ist und über mir
höre ich jetzt gerade den
Polizeihubschrauber der jetzt noch
einmal hier alle Straßen absucht ob dort
vielleicht der Schutz zu sehen ist und
die Beamten stehen mit Maschinenpistolen
im Anschlag in den Straßen rund um das
Gebetshaus und
so leicht kommt hier kein Autofahrer
durch die Sprachen jetzt von dem Täter
anfangs sprach die Polizei von dem oder
den Tätern ist inzwischen klar dass es
nur ein Täter war die Polizei geht
derzeit stark davon aus dass es ein
Täter war
prüft natürlich auch diese das wird
natürlich alles jetzt noch einmal
doppelt gecheckt ob es vielleicht doch
mehrere waren aber eben haben wir von
einem Polizeisprecher gehört dass es
sich um einen Schützen vermutlich
handelt sie sprachen jetzt von einem
Amoklauf gibt es denn irgendwelche
Umstände oder Details die Rückschlüsse
zulassen auf die Motivlage des Täters
naja man muss da einmal sich genau
angucken was in dem Gebäude zu der Zeit
los war es war eine Veranstaltung in
einer Kirche der Zeugen Jehovas also
möglicherweise kann dieser Amoklauf auch
religiöse Hintergründe haben aber genau
weiß man das nicht
das muss nun erst einmal die Polizei
prüfen gibt es irgendwelche
Informationen über den Täter
nein nicht nicht viele auch die Tatwaffe
er ist noch nicht sichergestellt worden
jetzt sieht es hier vor Ort so aus dass
erst einmal Erika Spezialkräfte also vor
diesem Gebäude stehen diese zwei
stöckigen Gebäude und sie haben es auch
schon durchsucht aber jetzt Regeln sie
den ganzen Straße davor noch einmal ab
und gut möglich dass sie gleich noch
einmal das Beule Gebäude ein weiteres
Mal durchsuchen wenn man von einem
Amoklauf spricht dann dürften die Motive
er in der Persönlichkeit des Täters
liegen gibt's denn irgendwelche Umstände
oder Hinweise die es ausschließen oder
naheliegen das auch ein terroristisches
Motiv dahinter stecken könnte
also das ist schwere zu früh um jetzt
darüber zu sprechen stand jetzt noch
nicht einmal klar wie viele Menschen
heute abend ums Leben gekommen sind auch
wie viele Verletzte es sind das ist
alles noch gar nicht klar es steht hier
den etwa 30 Journalisten am Rot-Weißen
Flatterband alle richtig ihre Kameras
auf das Gebäude aber viel mehr als das
hier oben über uns ein hubschrauberkreis
und Spezialkräfte vor dem Gebäude stehen
ist jetzt derzeit nicht zu sehen ich
weiß das ist schwer zu beurteilen aber
können sie aus dem Verhalten der
Polizisten vor Ort rückschließen ob die
Polizei noch nach dem Täter fahren wird
oder scheint die Situation sich eher
beruhigt zu haben weil die Polizei davon
ausgeht dass der Täter sich vielleicht
selbst gerichtet hat ich würde sagen die
Polizei spricht gerade
eine nicht ganz eindeutige Sprache denn
eben im Interview sagte der
Polizeisprecher es gibt keine Hinweise
darauf dass der Täter auf der Flucht ist
und
jetzt ist gerade der Polizeihubschrauber
gestartet dass wird eigentlich immer nur
dann so gemacht wenn die Beamten einen
Menschen suchen der möglicherweise auf
der Flucht sein könnte also es gibt hier
Widersprüche aber andererseits unterm
Strich keine Hinweise darauf dass der
Täter wirklich auf der Flucht ist also
dieser Hubschraubereinsatz ist
vielleicht auch einfach nur eine reine
Routine eine Vorsichtsmaßnahme soweit
die Informationen aus Hamburg durch
meinen Kollegen Kai sehr langander
herzlichen Dank und wenn es neue Dinge
zu vermelden gibt dann werden wir uns
dem Thema wieder widmen